i'm gonna do my catwalk
i'm so cool i cannot help the coolness
start the day gabby's gonna teach you
how to hit a bit listen if this is what
we're getting into that's what we're
getting okay i'm like [ __ ]
yeah don't don't mess with me boom
my problem is the like
like it's like
you need to keep it tight let me like
practice the fact that i
am a lover not a fighter
i don't know how to fight
i know people that are like actual
fighters i don't know about all that
okay okay all i know is if i'm hitting a
[ __ ] i'm here okay boom oh i can't get
tight and i'm going like boom oh okay
okay i never took your thumb because
that's how you break your thumb oh
no
i'm killing it
oh like this just looks so weak
but us we're getting out of bed before
noon today
we never do that
ever
all right so what happens we're in a
club okay
what happens a girl goes like this to
you
what do you do what do you say tell the
camera tell the camera this is what i
say excuse the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that that is the that
is the [ __ ] that gets you [ __ ] up
[ __ ] okay you're telling me
you're not gonna see me i'm six three
i'm a big [ __ ]
okay okay no no no no no no this is what
we're gonna change it to okay oh excuse
me
so gabby what are we gonna see today
no
no
no no no no it's like we don't assume
they did it on purpose
we assume it was an accident we assumed
the best
like oh excuse me
for you and instead of saying excuse the
[ __ ] me [ __ ] i says i says excuse the
frick me
female dog no no no
we just that might rub people the wrong
way right we're trying to assume that
but we're not trying to search oh
we don't want to rub people
we don't we don't want to rock people
the wrong way we're trying to avoid
conflict okay because what what good is
that we're avoiding conflict yeah so we
can say oh excuse me yeah excuse me yeah
excuse you [ __ ]
all right we'll work on it
i don't know what that is
this is a cool dinosaur apparently
called sophie
what did she do
one of the most like sources um
[Music]
really yeah you come here often
yeah
girl keeps talking about how smart we
are and everything that's going through
my head is
see button must push because there's
lots of buttons no gabby gabby
we're sharp we're so smart
i have to push a button
guys these are these are some some
molten earth
this is the earth the different
conditions of life
here's a planet you know
can you imagine going fishing i'm like
holy [ __ ]
do you see it
this is called a hot build baby
this is my other nickname
what
yeah
okay i like this one
because i'm horny
oh look this one it has lots of dollar
signs let's go we're trying to find
we're trying to find um
[Music]
a sugar daddy look it has lots of dollar
signs
well you just sit at the bar and hope
someone buys this food and it is
33 minutes on public okay gabby what did
you just do
flipped off a [ __ ] lesbian
okay gabby what are we talking about
next time what do you do cuss them out
no i don't no no what do you this wasn't
the sugar daddy spot we were hoping for
unfortunately
um i can't wait hold on i came here to
meet my rich future husband and
unfortunately
[Music]
we miss them it's okay
you do
[ __ ] off no no no we smile you give up
someone's staring at us we give them a
smile back you go
i'm six three people [ __ ] stare all
the time i'm not smiling at these
[ __ ] okay okay gab
okay
i thought we were trying
oh my god so
i tried to pick up my coffee again
this is where we're at
oh what happened no
i gripped the top oh my god it burns but
i like it
god damn it oh my god this is the
definition of hot messes
like that
how do i
when i look at i think it's a lost cause
no it's not
i'm not wasting your three pounds oh my
god
i bought her that latte i thought i was
gonna get some tonight
gabby what did you bring for the museum
today
my sparkling personality
and my diet
let's get some history [ __ ] and food
first because we're thick [ __ ] can't
act like this is going to be a regular
thing yes it's definitely not moving
i want that one
oh i like this one too
okay
gabby
[ __ ] marry kill with that one that one
that one the biggest one
which one i've been married
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
mary the richest one with that
first picture
i feel like i would be a good
wife oh cool
oh my god okay this is the type of [ __ ]
i'm talking about
i don't even know what i'm looking at
how's it going
crying be like that i'm telling you my
boyfriend did that too
them in the old days we didn't have food
like this
the old days
do you think i could have pulled him
do you want to
[Music]
okay i mean he's in a museum he probably
had money back then i'm sure like people
were poor back then it's like five cents
now yep everyone was dead broke i'm
trying to
tell you that this man wanted you is
that how like
you are right now i'd be lonely
i mean i just have so many like guys
just like lined up to date me it's like
crazy there's so many
so many
i just i can't can't keep
the men away
this is helena of troy do you think
she's hot question for the men
what
what else do you prefer kim kardashian's
or
kim k baby kim karen
he said that i decided to live my life
more delusional
being more delusional because
being i saw this tick tock and it was
like you should be delusional because
you like go for things you never would
like think that you could actually
achieve you know and i lived with this
one [ __ ] and she was delusional as [ __ ]
she was on her best lives i'm like [ __ ]
i'm gonna start being delusional i'm
like
i'm skinny